- La clientèle augmente
à la STM en raison, ent, du cene
qui se porte mieux.
AMÉLIE RÉGIS,
Société de transport de Montréal
l'interdiction du télétravail,
le 15 et depuis
la rentrée scolaire aussi,
en septembre, que..., les cliens
reviennent dans le réseau.
- Pour la semaine
du 29 novembre dernier,
et métro, 765 000 déplacements,
soit 61 % de plus qu'à
la même période en 2019.
Et en détail, on constate % part
à 2019 dans le métro
et une hausse de 65 %
dans les autobus.
on a vu que les stations
de métro du cent
ont connu la plus forte hausse
d'achalandage, justementeurs
reviennent... petit peu à petit
peu au centre-ville.
- La pandémie, surtout au début,
du transport en commun.
- Vraiment moins
en fait, pas du tout
la première année.suis
calmé l'angoisse, là.
- Depuis l'été 2020, je pense
sans problème, sans...
sans crainte, vraiment.
- Une inconnue plane,
du variant Omicron qui
pourrar l'achalandage.
Il y a aussi, et ca, c'est
nouveau, la nouvelle direcdu Quc
qui encourage maintenant
le retour du télétravail.
Mais la STM demeure optimiste.
relativement stable,
on prévoit que l'achalandage
devrait atteindre 75 à 90 % de
notre achalandage prépandémique
à l'automne 2ionale
de transport métropolitain,
, vient d'ailleurs
de mettre en place un tout
nouveau système de tarifs
justement, des habitudes
de déplacement d
en cette ère du télétravail.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,